même absentes de la ville ce matin la
manifestation des agriculteurs été
remarquable avec une est venue de g en
vider de ses bus et des déviations
organisé depuis 9 heures alors forcément
quand les tracteurs pénétrèrent dans la
cité quelques bouchons se créèrent dans
les artères adjacentes prendre la place
et ça prend apparemment beaucoup de
fumier donc je pense que je vais c'est
pas être derrière du fumier liant nu et
même du lisier devant le siège de la ddt
la direction départementale du
territoire
les agriculteurs membres de la fnsea et
leurs tracteurs ont donc fait une entrée
remarquée pour contester des normes
toujours plus contraignante de l'état et
le dumping environnemental et social
crée selon eux par bruxelles est vrai qu
on touche des subventions mais nos
produits on va dire ont des contraintes
pour respecter la consommation les
consommateurs mais on importe des pays
hors des produits des pays européens qui
sont en fait vous ré de produits qui
nous sont interdits knoxy sont interdits
et toxiques pour le consommateur
français ça serait bien que on est tous
les mêmes règles intérieures d'europe
après le défilé
la démonstration de force place jean
jaurès ou 150 engins ont convergé
certains ont déversé du fumier et du
lisier ou encore de la nourriture pour
animaux
le message à la population s'était
servez-vous nous ne pouvons plus
l'utiliser le message aux institutions
c'était de contester l'extension de la
zone vulnérable en indre et loire qui
oblige les éleveurs à stocker et non
plus répandre certains produits
le lisier par exemple je dis pas qu'il
ne faut pas de norme parce que façon
cvac cdma thiès et des matières
polluantes il faut encadrer mais faut
pas exagérer dans l'encadrement ya un
moment il ya quelques il ya deux ans ne
s'est déjà mis des contraintes en place
aujourd'hui on nous remet des
contraintes supplémentaires sans
attendre de voir le résultat des
contrôles qu'on a déjà mis en place
autre grief de l'union départementale
des syndicats d'exploitants agricoles
lecomte pénibilité considéré comme une
surcharge administrative insupportable
chaque matin il faudra faire une fiche
de travail considérant le
quel travail il va ya voir ça sera pas
le même le même le même flamme mp
visibilité sera pas le même compte par
rapport au travail qui fait on sait
quand mon mari cole le travail est très
diverses
je pense qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose de beaucoup plus générale d'hier
le monde agricole et est pénible et dire
le prendre en compte d'une façon plus
générale après une rencontre en
préfecture la question de la zone
vulnérable a été évoquée et pourrait
être diminué à hauteur de 40% dans ce
cas le fumier ne sera plus distribué à
la population